it sounds like you kind of um made what
i call making your wounds your work
right like i did something similar with
my channel too right and um
you know you took that trauma of um you
know the wounds that you were dealing
with and you kind of made it like the
body of your work you created the
podcast you created your
um i think it's um it's a community
called the iron council is it
it is yeah that's our kind of our
exclusive brotherhood that we have yeah
can you can you talk about the podcast
and how that started to take off and and
how that changed your life
i i think your
your wounds or your work is a great way
to put it um i created something that i
needed you know i didn't have it i
looked around and i was like man i
really need some guys in my corner you
know i had forsaken all my friends
because i got married and that's one of
the first things to go is your your own
health and then your buddies
so
i felt like a
i honestly i felt like a sack of [ __ ]
like calling my friends up and said hey
bro my wife left me can we hang out so i
didn't even do that because i felt like
such a loser um so i had to go out and
find new friends but the guys that i was
surrounded with seemed more interested
in the party or the whatever that i that
i was video games things that i wasn't
interested in so i'm like man what what
is out there you know what's out there
and there were some things like art of
manliness was a big
influence early on for me and i think
brett mckay does some incredible work in
fact i still am connected with him and
follow him closely
um but i thought there was a big
disconnect between the information that
we as men have access to and then what
we're actually doing and nobody was in
my corner saying ryan you're failing
you're struggling here's what you should
do here's how you should fix it so i
said all right well i gotta create it
and i had a podcast um before order of
man called wealth anatomy and i was
focused on giving financial advice to
medical professionals because that was
my line of work uh and i realized man i
love podcasting i love getting behind
this microphone and having these
conversations i don't wanna have that
conversation but there's a handful of
guys i want to talk with because i need
some mentorship i need some guidance and
direction in my life uh but they don't
have any reason to talk with me so i'll
create a podcast and tell them i'll
promote it to my audience who was
probably like two people at that point
um and it worked you know like they i'm
the biggest recipient even to this day
850 plus podcasts later man every time i
get to have a conversation with you or
other people i'm like dang
like this is my job really this is
awesome yeah oh it's been powerful yeah
it's pretty awesome being able to have
enough influence where you can reach out
to some interesting people and have um
you know beyond interesting
conversations hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you